c'est le passage obligé pour rejoindre
paris depuis la haute saône et même
depuis le territoire de belfort la
fameuse nationale 19 un axe très
fréquenté
laurent fait le trajet tous les jours
depuis plus de dix ans de vesoul à
langres en haute marne 77 km à rouler
avant de récupérer l'autoroute
cette route la connais par coeur sept au
départ tu es une route qui sont assez
difficiles
par deux fois deux voies qui y est pas
mal de village à traverser une route on
va dire une route qui n'est pas adaptée
au trafic de maintenance un constat plus
que partagés chez les professionnels de
la route ici en haute saône avec
pratiquement six mille véhicules par
jour dont 1000 camions la nationale 10 9
n'est qu'une route à deux voies de vaud
où la langue et elle traverse de
nombreux villages se transporter à une
flotte de 70 camions il est installé à
côté de vesoul
on va partout en france on s'aperçoit
que les infrastructures partout ont
évolué ça évolue alors voilà j'ai
expliqué en lorraine en alsace en
bretagne ça bouge et nous ça bouge pas
quoi pourtant économiquement parlant la
haute saône a des atouts non
négligeables dû à sa position
géographique à la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de vesoul le dossier de
l'autoroute est souvent évoquée
je pense que l'autoroute est plus
adéquat parce que aujourd'hui les deux
fois de voir si je ne m'abuse c'est
plutôt financement état région
département et là je pense que on est un
petit peu coincé donc à partir de là il
reste l'autoroute puisque l'autoroute
pourrait être privée la national 19 un
véritable serpent de mer en saône qui
depuis plus de 30 ans à nîmes tissu
politique économique départemental alain
joyandet anciens ministres actuellement
sénateur a toujours milité comme
d'autres élus pour la construction d'une
autoroute entre l'ong et vesoul un
projet dans les cartons qui risque d'y
rester
alors nous on nous amuse un peu nous
expliquant que c'est mieux avec une deux
fois deux voies dit c'est mieux parce
que c'est gratuit
sauf que la deux fois deux voies on a
commencé les travaux adel
il ya 20 ans on n'a toujours pas à
vesoul et donc si on attend encore 30
ans pour arriver à langres imaginez
quand même l'avenir de nos enfants dans
un département qui est quasiment le seul
à ne pas avoir
un kilomètre d'autoroute alors que
commence à sortir de terre la déviation
de port-sur-saône un chantier
gigantesque de 8 km qui se terminera en
2020 et qui potentiellement aurait pu se
raccorder à un réseau autoroutier
un rapport du conseil d'orientation des
infrastructures le fameux rapport du
romy fin février à la ministre des
transports préconise tout simplement
l'abandon total du projet d'autoroute
langres vesoul
michel neugnot vice président de la
région bourgogne franche comté a
participé à ce rapport et il propose que
dans le cadre des financements
complémentaires de la fiq
on rajoute 80 millions pour le
contournement de langues et 30 millions
pour terminer les contournements de port
sur saône et réaliser un certain nombre
d'évitement pour permettre aux camions
de se doubler sur cet axe des
propositions qui ne sont pas les
bienvenues en haute saône
les élus du département présidente du
conseil départemental sénateur maire
l'ont réaffirmé fin mars
il doit y avoir un axe autoroutier entre
vesoul et langues
le dossier de l'a319 est loin mais très
très loin d'être terminée